-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Nicolle Wallace.
Nicolle, today was harrowing
and terrifying.
In an effort to
lighten things up a little bit,
there is a great new development
in television,
which is my dear friend Leslie
Jones has started watching MSNBC
and basically live-tweeting it
for what seems like
multiple hours a day.
Are you aware of this?
-I am a groupie.
I mean, I'm like whatever
10 steps past a fan is.
And we love her
so much in my house
that my son
watches some of them.
We do earmuffs
for the bad language.
-Bet you got to do a lot of
earmuffs when it's Leslie Jones.
-When he put my glasses on,
my son now talks like Leslie.
You know, "Nikki putting
her glasses on!" you know.
We love her. We love her.
-Yeah. Just for those
who haven't seen,
here's a quick clip
of how Leslie reacts
when she's watching Nicolle
on MSNBC.
-Yas, Nicolle!
Yas, Joy!
Y'all look good with your pink
and your purple!
Look at Joy! Beautiful smile!
Look at Nicolle!
Where your glasses at, Nicolle?
We gon' need them.
-She mentioned the glasses
right there.
She very much likes the Nicolle
move of putting the glasses on.
-Well, I'm blind as a bat,
so I think --
Tucker Carlson once made fun
of me for doing it for show,
but I wish that were the case.
I'm blind as a bat,
so I can't read a thing.
-Gotcha. So, what presents
as you're about to get serious
is in reality, you have to
put them on to read.
-Well, and you'll appreciate
that sometimes it's
I have no idea what's next,
so I put on my glasses
to see, you know...
-Right, of course. Yeah.
-...what I'm supposed
to be doing.
-I have been there, as well.
Hey, I want to talk
about last night.
You know, we did have
this election result.
And, you know,
we had two candidates
that, you know, were I guess
endorsed by the president,
though it seemed like
he was putting more energy
in talking about himself than
he was in talking about them.
What was your takeaway
insofar as how Trump affected
last night's results?
-Look, I think
what happened last night
is very much connected
to what happened today
in good and bad ways.
I mean, President-Elect Biden
and his new attorney general --
We learned today
who that's going to be.
It's going to be
Merrick Garland,
who President Obama had
nominated to the Supreme Court
and Mitch McConnell blocked.
They're going to
have to really look
at investigating the president
and investigating his supporters
and people that were there.
And that's just one department.
That's DOJ.
The Biden agenda, they --
I talked to a person in
the incoming Biden White House,
and she said to me, "We don't
know what we don't know."
I think it is so important
that Biden can move at lightning
speed in the beginning
to get vaccines into our arms.
I mean, we haven't even
mentioned it yet,
but I think almost 4,000 people
died today of COVID.
So President-Elect Biden
has his hands full.
And it is a really,
really, really good thing
that he's going to have control,
his party controlling
the Senate,
so that he can get, at least
for the first two years,
as much of his agenda
through as possible.
-Do you think
that historians will look back
on the way the president
involved himself in this race
and frame it as maybe
one of the worst strategies?
-I hope it's something bigger.
I mean, I hope it goes back to
what you said in the beginning,
and I hope that we can add
voters rejecting.
I mean, Kelly Loeffler and David
Perdue were coup enthusiasts.
They were for overturning the
results of November's election.
And I think that if you can take
any sort of solace
in some of what we've seen,
is that in November, Donald
Trump was roundly rejected,
and in Georgia, his allies,
who had wrapped themselves
around him --
He was at war
with their own Republican
statewide elected officials.
All of the statewide electeds
in Georgia are Republicans.
Secretary of State
Raffensperger,
Governor Kemp, Gabe Sterling,
these people who,
in comparison to all of
the Republicans in Washington
look like truth-tellers
and heroes, were actually,
until Trump started fighting
his election loss,
likely allies
of Perdue and Kelly.
So it's a good thing
for the country
that Georgia rejected them.
We'll see if Democrats
can continue that streak.
But I think
if we can extrapolate
that Reverend Warnock and Jon
Ossoff were superb candidates
who ran very
disciplined campaigns
during a time
of incredible turmoil --
President-Elect Biden
went to the state and campaigned
and kept the message very
forward-looking, very positive.
And it's good
that Georgians selected that.
But I think that it is --
It would be unfair
to sort of understate
just how challenging
the governing climate will be
for Joe Biden and Democrats
in the Congress.
-I do want to swing back
to something you said
about the elected officials
in Georgia,
Raffensperger,
Sterling, and Kemp,
who have defended
time and time again
the authenticity
and, you know, the effectiveness
of the electoral process
in Georgia,
and the very fact
that the Republicans
and the Republican Party
would certainly espouse
the idea of states' rights.
And yet you have,
not to go back to it,
but you have, you know, Senator
Hawley today who's from Missouri
talking about how Pennsylvania
should run their elections.
Does that sort of speak to, you
know, how little meat there is
on the bones
of what they're criticizing,
when the states that are, again,
Republican-run states
are saying, "Hey, guys, we're
the ones on the ground here.
We're also upset
with the results,
but we can promise you
this has been fair and square"?
-Yeah, look,
I mean, it's worse --
It's more egregious than that.
And it means there's no marrow
inside the bones
of today's Republican Party.
They're soulless.
They're without principle.
Their ambition has blinded them
from any --
Think about
what they strive to do.
Their ambition means
they want to be the next
president of this country,
a country
that they don't respect
or hold in high enough regard
to honor a choice
that this country made
in a democratic election.
So I think that they have been
revealed in Washington
by some of these statewide
Republican officials who were --
I mean, Georgia's
Republican governor
is as Trumpy as you can get.
He was in a fight with
Atlanta Mayor Bottoms for months
about mask-wearing.
I mean, these were not
"squishy" Republicans.
These were Georgia Republicans.
And to see Josh Hawley,
the Ivy League-educated Josh
Hawley, trying to undermine
other Democratic and Republican
statewide officials
just shows how hollow and craven
and how sort of driven
by political ambition he is.
And it's sad that we're even
talking about him,
but he deserves
a lot of the blame
for what happened
in Congress today.
-Once again, I really do
want to thank you,
after basically what I think
is about 24 hours on television,
that you found
an extra 15 minutes for us.
Thanks so much, Nicolle.
-It's an honor. Thank you.